Le drame se serait produit mardi en toute
fin d'après-midi.
Mais ce n'est que ce matin que les corps sans
vie de deux hommes d'une cinquantaine d'années
ont été retrouvés ici, au domaine Porcheron
de Fontenay-près-Chablis.
Ces deux hommes seraient deux frères qui
appartenaient au domaine viticole.
Ils évoluaient dans une cuve qui était actuellement
en travaux pour une mise aux normes.
Seule certitude qui nous a été communiquée
ce matin par la procureure de la République d'Auxerre,
c'est que la piste accidentelle serait à privilégier.
Une disqueuse thermique a été saisie.
Pour l'instant le périmètre est bouclé
ici autour du domaine Porcheron.
La section scientifique de la gendarmerie
et le médecin légiste
sont actuellement en train de travailler pour
tenter de déterminer les causes de ces décès.